let's let's let's let's talk about this
report first
uh as many of you are aware we are not
allowed to make
specific claims on youtube they will
remove the live stream
but we have this report from allied
security group which got released
earlier today
a judge ordered it be released and it
let me just read you
one one quote from section b from
section b
subsection two saying we conclude that
dominion voting systems
intentionally and purposefully designed
with inherent errors
to create systemic fraud and influence
election results
the system intentionally generates an
enormously high number of ballot errors
the electronic ballots are then
transferred for adjudication
the intentional errors lead to bulk
adjudication of ballots with no
oversight no transparency and no audit
trail
this leads to voter or election fraud
based on our study we conclude that the
dominion voting system should not be
used in michigan
we further conclude the results of
antrim county should not have been
certified
now let's talk about who this guy is
they say who we are the first guy
my name is russell james ramsen jr and
i'm a resident of dallas county texas i
hold an mba from harvard university
and a political science degree from duke
university i've worked with the national
aeronautics and space administration
and the massachusetts institute of
technology among other organizations and
have run businesses all over the world
many which are highly technical in
nature i have served on technical
government panels so this has been one
of the biggest stories of the day
interestingly if you google search this
and you try and look it up
you're not going to find the report
you're going to find a lot of articles
saying
unproven baseless trump supporters and
things like that
which is very strange framing for a news
organization because even if you don't
agree with this guy or you think he's a
hack or you think he's just trying to
help trump
you'd simply say an independent audit
you know uh
as the result of a lawsuit from
republicans made these claims
that's just the news if you want to
argue this guy is biased or right or
wrong
i mean you can but what's what's weird
is that you go on google you try and
find the story
they don't tell you what's in the report
they just say trump supporters
are pushing claims
i know you hunter had some opinions
about this guy too so
yeah do you want to you want to express
those opinions yeah sure absolutely in
the marketplace of ideas right
yes um yeah i mean i i don't
agree that we should just be like
attacking someone's credentials i don't
think that that's
necessarily an argument against the
report i do however think that this
guy's credentials are important when we
talk about the likelihood of bias in his
report
so because he has been a republican
lawmaker i think or i know for a fact
that he's donated a couple thousand
dollars to
different gop people or whatnot um he
was hired by the trump admin
um and it's very uh very very frequent
for consultants to come to the
conclusions that
support the lawsuit so i don't think
that that necessarily
means that this report should be
completely ignored but i do think that
if anything what we should take that we
should look at this report with a grain
of salt
and take that uh maybe as an indication
that we need a
better more thorough and more
independent audit of these machines
i would 100 be in support of an
independent audit of dominion voting
machines because since i don't really
think voter fraud is
you know a big issue uh i would be more
than happy to see that audited and
hopefully the findings would you know
that's the right answer
yeah why has it been like pulling teeth
that you know because it had to go to a
judge to get this released why were the
why would the democrats try to block it
from being released
yeah i mean i i don't know i know what i
was what i read today was
i don't remember who said what but i
know that one of them said we're not
really trying to hide anything you can
go ahead and release the thing if you
want to
uh i know that the report is
it's it has a lot of misinformation or
at very least it has information that is
quite similar to previous
unfounded voter fraud claims that have
already been kind of debunked that's
interesting
wouldn't this bunk them what do you mean
so like if they said they were unfounded
claims isn't this founding them
well because they actually analyzed 22
machines right right well no because i
do think that this is extremely
susceptible to bias
and even more so i mean if do you want
to say no yeah i would question that
because
a lot of other people like john oliver
when it came to his show last week
tonight almost
last year made very similar claims on
his hbo show
warning us about dominion warning us
about the accountability warning us
about the numbers
almost very similarly to the report that
was just released by the republicans but
this was an argument being made by
let's just say the kind of leftist
establishment institutions when it was
against
you know this larger idea of russian
collusion so what do you think of like
other
proponents of the left saying this
election was a fraud
four years ago and now like john oliver
oddly kind of changing their minds
specifically john oliver about a year
ago produced a 20-minute segment
and targeted like a bunch of these
voting machines including dominion for
the susceptibility to fraud how very how
it was really really easy
now we have republicans saying wow look
at all this and now it's the
establishment left saying no no that
can't possibly be the case
i'm not too familiar with john oliver i
don't even watch him i don't really like
him very much to be honest um i guess i
would just want to know like if you
think that the
if they have a uh um an error rate of
close to 70 percent
do you think we would have discovered
that sooner than now
68.05 so i think just just to cite what
you're saying
the tabulation log this is from section
eight uh for the forensic for the for
the forensic examination of the server
in antrim county for december 6 2020
consists of 15
676 individual events of which 10
667 or 68.05 of the events were recorded
errors
these errors resulted in overall
tabulation errors or ballots being sent
to adjudication
the high error rate proves the dominion
voting voting system is flawed and does
not meet state or federal election laws
uh yeah we did find it texas rejected
the machines yeah i mean i
i i'm again i'm not familiar with every
individual you know talk show host or
texas or or stuff like that but i do
think that um
when do you think that this is
susceptible to bias do you think that
guy sounds cool
absolutely yeah well as as for you know
whether he sounds like he's biased
i think one simple thing is true do you
think he's lying under oath with his
with his presentation
was he under oath you know i just
yeah this evidence that i have is proof
so that that's a red flag
it is i mean one of one of his claims
was that i don't know if it was under
oath actually one of his claims was that
he um
was that the it was a a system error
rather than a human error yes voting
system right but i know that one of the
people i think it was a gop uh
eisenhower i don't remember his first
name um he was the one that
made the error he was a republican he
made the error and in andrew
yeah i believe so and didn't he even say
like acknowledge that
that he was the one that made that error
i can i can pull this up really quick
from where i'm reading from yeah see if
you can pull put up because i'm not
super
familiar uh my thing is like is this guy
putting factually baseless statements
about numbers and just like making up
numbers and then giving them to a court
you know yeah i don't think that i i i
don't like
there's no i don't think there's a grand
conspiracy i think trump certainly is
you know spitting and yelling but if
there's a grand conspiracy bill barr
would have just
launched investigations and done what
trump wanted and if he's under oath he
would go to jail
i don't know if he was under rose we
don't know yet but if he was which you
know
most court proceedings most evidence is
under yeah i can't imagine perjury
you know yeah if he if he faked these
numbers and gave him to a judge
or present him to a court i can't
imagine no i don't i don't think that
he's just
like lying don't don't get me wrong i
don't think this guy's just making up
some bs report and then just
like lying about it under oath or
whether he's under earth or not
regardless i don't think he's lying
about it i think that
he probably did do something one way or
another to get
that error rate as high as possible
uh now this is only a theory of mine
that i have because again we're kind of
still waiting for more info on this this
subject
as well um but i know that in antrim
county there were a lot of errors
at first that were then later fixed so
my thought process was
perhaps he was counting that error rate
before the errors were fixed
which could be a possibility um and if
he was that would mean that there's
probably a ton of errors in other places
that weren't caught and weren't fixed
i mean maybe this is why i would be all
for like an independent
non-partisan nonpartisan investigation i
know that dominion voting machines
have been under rigorous tests before
both state level and national testing
and have been rejected because of it
they have been in texas texas rejected
them after doing a test
when was this so i don't know the exact
year but when when dominion went to
texas
and said we want to use these voting
machines they did test on them and say
whoa no way we can't use these
they're bad i would i would just want to
know how long ago that was i mean
yeah i know that in the beginning at the
beginning stages i'm sure that they were
much less unreliable but they've been
being used for a long time now
i think also that if we were if we were
using voting machines that had such
significant error rates i
kind of think we would have discovered
that sooner um
and again if his report was there's an
error rate and that's concerning that's
one thing
but the fact that he's trying to claim
that that's a system
fault it was january of this year texas
rejected the machines
yeah after they did tests on them from
the texan texas rejected use of dominion
voting system software due to efficiency
issues
right right for efficiency problems so
not necessarily susceptibility to error
i think pretty important but that's a
pretty important distinction right at
the end of it if we all agree we should
have an audit
then we should have like another audit
or something who should audit it
what we uh that's the problem no one's
ever gonna be satisfied well i
i i would be satisfied if it was a a
actual
like independent nonpartisan thing i
just i i have a tough time and i think
that
people watching and i'm sure tim you can
understand too i do have a little bit of
a hard time trusting that report when it
comes from someone
who is so obviously in favor of donald
trump and the conclusion that
that's a really good point because i
have the equal feeling about mainstream
media organizations who 90
of their stories are negative about
trump or 90 plus so why would i trust
them when they come out and say the
inverse
you see the problem yeah yeah yeah i
think that the mainstream media is very
like and they don't like trump that's
for sure so what do we do
you know it's like weird that they were
blocking this and then they eventually
agreed to let it go like this monday
but it's it's i think one of the biggest
problems we're having right now
is we don't really have time after an
election
to do any kind of legitimate hardcore
doj style analysis
you know or investigation we've got
what a month to certify all the results
do all the counting takes forever
right and then once you do the election
contests the official like okay i'm
challenging these results only happens
after a certification so you they
all these lawsuits pop up because
they're gonna then they certify
then you can start challenging the you
know the votes and the elections and all
that stuff
how do we even get to that point where
we're going to investigate
150 million votes probably tens of
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
voting machines across the country
it's just it's impossible yeah and the
exploitation
you know like like it's securing a cyber
infrastructure
is basically impossible so as time goes
on and our population grows and there's
more votes
the easier it will be for someone to
cheat that's just a limitation of
investigatory powers
sure i think that that's definitely true
and i think that the more people that
vote
obviously we're going to see with that
an uptick in
some voter fraud as well um and i don't
would never deny that voter fraud
happens of course
like people like when they have 300
million well that's not how many people
vote but when you have
hundreds of millions of people right
voting like of course you're gonna have
some fraud but
there's overall been a lot of
comprehensive studies collected on this
just pull it out of the wall sorry man
that's okay i was saying how both you
guys made kind of good points here
there should be a bipartisan kind of
approach towards this but at the same
time we're in a
time crunch uh when it comes to big
companies overseeing this election there
should be a lot more scrutiny
a lot more oversight and uh i mean i'm
with john oliver there's there's
something that stinks with uh dominion i
think there's a lot of i don't know
he changed his position he of course
changed his position now but i agree
with john oliver a year ago when donald
trump was in office
now that joe biden is in office i
disagree well technically he had a whole
big
coughing speech today yes uh which
everyone's which everyone is talking
about
on twitter just right before the show
went on uh highlighting how he was
coughing his way through his
is that how they're gonna do it is that
how come harris becomes president that's
it i don't know but there's a lot of
people from
left-leaning twitter accounts saying god
i hope he doesn't have the coronavirus
from his latest speech that's literally
what i'm seeing right now maybe that's
maybe that's the next plan maybe that
well maybe that's the next big leftist
plan is to infect biden with kovid so
that he dies and then they can boom get
count
i mean that's that's basically been the
theory that was the plan all along
anyway that's what i've heard anyway
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you